dino archie comic shouts had a thing
that could be funny he said drake is
toxic dudes taylor swift like if you're
a [ __ ] boy you've that's your taylor
swift he makes you feel that [ __ ] where
you're like oh yo i love everything i'm
this is aspirational for me the way he
talks about women the way he talks about
living and partying that [ __ ] is
aspirational for me yeah yeah 100
yeah
yeah you're right i think you're
describing it accurately
yeah yeah
i didn't feel that [ __ ] boy
this album in the car i swear to you
four songs in i was about to fall asleep
clb i couldn't ah you crazy the first
hidden the first song champagne poetry
is like where are the and you said this
in the text and i had the same thought
where are the [ __ ] bangers there's no
trophies there's no [ __ ] starter from
the bottom there's not even the what's
the r b [ __ ] the hold on we're going
home or whatever
that [ __ ] goes controller goes i didn't
feel that and i'm sure he's going to
have hits and he's got this video with
kawhi for too sexy and that [ __ ] i'm
sure is going to go off cause he's
really [ __ ] smart yeah but i did not
listen to most of the i was like yeah
it's just not for me i guess because i
was like i'll this play this [ __ ] for
adonis when he won't sleep
he jumps sleeping you put this [ __ ] on i
promise you he's out like a light it's
not like a light yeah it's not for you
it's he makes music for women and uh
[ __ ] boys right and uh and he doesn't
make music for like tough guys he makes
move for like guys who get their
eyebrows done right right but not
because they're gay because they're like
i'm gonna get more [ __ ] and my
eyebrows look good like
their whole focus is getting [ __ ] and
make fun of if you want to i got more
[ __ ] than you like guys that like
like
go like that a lot yeah like
mouth and [ __ ] like that like their
whole [ __ ] is like trying to look good
that is who he makes music for and women
and women [ __ ] love it women are
going to bump this [ __ ] until they end
up kanye makes music for one person
he doesn't make music for anybody else
kanye how do i serve what i want with
this music and
sometimes that's amazing because you get
something different kanye might be
feeling different yep you know and he's
going to put something else out but in
terms of bars drake for me way more
authentic says the things that are
aspirational says lines where i'm like
oh that was [ __ ] fire same way that
jay-z does like you're like holy [ __ ] i
love that i love what you just said
you know and uh
kanye just doesn't do that for me
thoughts guys
i mean you pretty much wrapped it up if
i had to compare both albums there you
can't compare it they're two different
genres they're two which did you enjoy
more
i think that's a pretty easy truthfully
i
think donda is better in terms of an art
piece but uh clb is more enjoyable just
to listen to while i'm just like
cruising or whatever what i'm doing yeah
okay that's how i feel about it yeah but
i think donda is a better work of art
yeah yeah i feel the same way and if you
take the hits off donda and just make
like that 10 song playlist yep like i'm
gonna bump that like i'm like yeah this
is a fire album right here these ten
songs so if i'm looking at like a whole
album like i was saying before like yeah
i'm gonna say clb is probably a better
collection of music consistently yeah
eight out of ten seven point five out of
ten
but and then donda has a plus pluses and
it also has like some c's and d's yeah
so i'm like all right but i do agree
with the comparison thing this is what i
was saying before is like it is kind of
unfair to compare them but at the same
time that's on kanye for putting himself
in the comparison
like he inserted himself and said yo
drake we're like i'm going for you i
want everyone to compare these two
albums listen to both of them side by
side yeah and these are like i want you
guys to really make a judgment now it's
like it's kind of a disservice to you i
want to ask you as a question though
because you probably saw the streaming
numbers
yeah i thought it was an interesting
thing that happened yeah so kanye's
streaming number
was 95 i think for or 94 something like
that first day like 9.50 uh sorry like
950. 95 million i think 95 million yeah
and then 104 million the second day
right yeah and then drake's was 154
million the first day and then like 83
or something like that the second day
right
now drake still has more total
but
interesting that
more people started bumping yay the
second day yeah
less
drake thoughts on that i think this was
a i would think again not a drake fan
but i would assume unless i was a
massive massive stan i would be like
this is disappointing relative to these
other albums
i think that's why the numbers cut in
half people didn't and you said before
it happened you were like i'll listen to
kanye once and i listen to drake over
and over and over yeah that kind of
proves that didn't happen with this
album if the second day the numbers are
in half people didn't listen to it over
and over they didn't do it over and they
said i'm done yeah put on something else
kanye we're like all right let me see if
i missed something let me let me hear
this one more time yeah i'm wondering
like
do you guys use music for
mood stabilization or mood motivation
yeah yes okay right so like
um let's say for example you wanna i
know when we were doing netflix there
were certain songs that i was like i i
need to feel today that i'm gonna
conquer the world yeah i haven't slept
for three hours i'm on a [ __ ]
treadmill but when i run on this
treadmill i want to feel like i am about
to tear people's [ __ ] heads off right
and it's like and music can put you in
that state if it's really good yes right
i don't know this song on clb that
changes my state yet champagne poetry a
little bit is kind of like celebration
it's like
it's like yeah we did it we out here
like the crew it felt very like crew
inspired which i really liked right it's
kind of how we operate so it was cool to
see everybody moving but i'm like i
didn't go where do i want to feel
something
on donda there's a few songs that i can
go to when i want to feel something yeah
they're evoking emote an emotion and and
they're motivating me to have that
emotion do you guys feel that at all for
for a certified lover boy is that like a
song where like this is going to make me
feel something and no that's where i'm
like that's why i think this is a
disappointing album because he's good
for making you feel things trophies that
[ __ ] beat i made drake hater i hear
that beat on my left goal bro yeah from
the bottom now here let's go you're
motivated on some level controller makes
you feel something you get in some kind
of mood different mood yeah but
something i didn't feel that about any
of these tracks yeah i like uh working
on a weekend like usual right right like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] makes you go like yeah we
out here but that's to the point of like
what who's it for like who's the album
for yeah you know what i mean like if
it's four [ __ ] boys and if it's for like
single women like you're neither of
those things so it's like yo if i'm
driving home with two chicks like i'm
playing girls want girls you know what i
mean like if i'm at the club like if i'm
doing a house party just kind of like a
kickback with some chicks like yeah i'm
gonna play that like i wanna play race
my mind or whatever tsu like get the
girls going crazy actual question not
arguing would you say it's on the same
level as like uh hold on we're going
home or controlling the other [ __ ] that
i named like where if you're like i'm
i'm playing this for [ __ ] let's put
this on it potentially could be
potentially could because i think this
is that those songs were for us more
yeah trophies for us it's nice for us
that's not foreign
control is not for us what's the other
one hotline bling's not for us that [ __ ]
goes he's got like i haven't been
highlighting passion yeah but girls are
that's what i'm saying i don't think
that [ __ ] goes i think that's what
mark's point is he's saying that girls
are relating to these songs and there
aren't a lot of songs here for guys to
just flex on and and that's why we
the song might be or the album might be
super motivational at least emotionally
we just don't have those emotions or
don't want to access those emotions yeah
there are guys that are playing too sexy
like way too sexy like unironically yeah
that are like sitting in their car
bumping and being like they're there
legit they got their eyebrows done they
got their [ __ ] forehead and yeah
and the way you can tell the most stream
song was girls want girls yo and because
girls flocked together can i tell you
something i was shocked on that song oh
a little baby
that's what i think has a lot to do with
it too no that has something to do with
it
sorry sorry he killed it definitely has
it definitely has something to do with
it but this is what made me feel like
like my girl is the litmus test for
for me for pop culture
if it's right like she's so detached
from pop culture yeah like she has no
idea who little baby is yeah she has no
idea who these like i'd be shocked if
she knows who future is yeah like that's
how detached she is
i asked her if she listened to drake and
i was like what song she's like i liked
one song the girls girls one yeah
i'm like oh
this hits yeah yeah girls are into this
[ __ ] now i get again little baby streams
well i wasn't trying to discredit
completely but there's something about
it that girls are into it that's funny
because i play this for my wife as we're
driving and she's like can we change it
and she's normally a drake fan yeah so
that's why i'm like oh i think this
album is disappointing to a lot of fans
i'm sure a ton of people still love it
yeah i think a lot of people were
disappointed and i
thought i think i also thought drake
would knock this [ __ ] out of the park i
thought it wasn't even gonna be close
he's a [ __ ] he's a brilliant dude the
sports center hacked to announce the
album kanye's album came people were
kind of disappointed yeah i was like
he's ready to [ __ ] wipe kanye off the
mountain he did and they doubled them